this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman also take a
look at movies and TV shows where the
people making them really should [ __ ]
know better they film these things they
should know what they're putting on film
before it reaches the audience these
[ __ ] who do this stuff yet
invariably stuff slips through the
cracks and we call that stuff [ __ ] that
should not be this week [ __ ] that should
not be comes from listener Joshua Paul
Hawkins from Seattle Washington the
movie in question is Jay and Silent Bob
strike back now the whole [ __ ] movie
[ __ ] that guy it's only one scene this
is a scene where the lead characters of
Jay and Silent Bob are in a mooby's
fast-food restaurant and there's an
internet kiosk there and they use that
kiosk to respond to some internet hatred
at one of the movie review websites
they're saying some bad things about the
upcoming film about Jay and Silent Bob
that's being made by Miramax and so they
they take the opportunity to hop on this
internet kiosk and type away furiously
some some rejoinders that Jay comes up
with while Silent Bob does the typing I
implore you to watch carefully as Silent
Bob does the typing
it's time we brought something back type
this [ __ ] down all you [ __ ] are
gonna pay spacebar spacebar spacebar
spacebar spacebar spacebar
are you watching cry like little whiny
[ __ ] want to get spacebar spacebar
spacebar spacebar spacebar spacebar
spacebar spacebar spacebar we're in a
rare position we never get to do this
but I could actually tell you the moment
that happened and [ __ ] why it was
that way so I could because they were
running a camera on it they didn't want
me to just [ __ ] type because what if
I [ __ ] up the typing blah blah blah
so there's a program and the program the
way that makes it you know look like
it's being typed on screen right all you
have to do is hit the spacebar huh
obvious yeah so so on the day we're
shooting that and I'm like I really feel
like I should hit the keys it was told
and was literally told this by Scott
Mosier you think anyone's watching that
closely
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]